at this medical clinic a rush to get as
many Jabs in his many arms as quickly as
possible inside these vials is not a
coveted vaccine but instead a vaccine
for polio
yes polio ready the highly infectious
devastating virus that can cause
paralysis polio has been discovered in
the Wastewater in two areas of New York
paralyzing an unvaccinated 20 year old
man who had traveled to Europe for every
one case of paralytic polio there's
probably hundreds of other pieces that
are going undetected and so that's very
worrisome the Centers for Disease
Control and prevention or CDC is so
concerned about polio being found in New
York they've sent a team of experts to
investigate and try to contain it as
quickly as possible
this is the epicenter of the polio
outbreak in America New York's Rockland
and orange counties otherwise quiet
areas about an hour north of New York
City as health officials try to get
people vaccinated complicating matters
this area is home to a lot of
ultra-conservative Orthodox Jews many of
whom refuse vaccinations because of
religious Doctrine Orthodox Jewish
population that has been relatively
closed we do have communication with
them through their rabbis and make sure
that they understand how critical it is
that the people get vaccinated
there are some groups that tend to say
well God will protect me but look if you
take that view then you can't really go
to the doctor it's God has sent us
vaccines God has sent us doctors God has
let us understand polio and how it works
I think God wants us to use vaccines
suddenly any invention that helps polio
patients towards recovery is as welcome
as it is important polio struck fear in
people in the 1940s paralyzing over 30
000 people a year in the U.S before
vaccinations were made readily available
in 1955.
when I was a little kid I had Polio you
don't want polio it is paralyzing it is
awful and it can kill the battle against
polio is back on and at least in one
part of America where the rush is not
only to get people vaccinated but also
convince those who are reluctant
Gabriel Elizondo Al Jazeera New York